well listen when i heard you were doing
a daytime show
i was like this is exactly what the
world needs and then i heard that it was
going to be on our network
and i was thinking oh my goodness how
did they
hold everything aligned so tell us a
little bit about
what is this show going to be well
first of all thank you for the amazingly
kind words you just said
um i i actually made a documentary
called the making of it's on our youtube
channel for the show
if you know anyone is interested in how
and why and where and when this show has
been
in the making for a year and in this
year
and it has been an extraordinary journey
very humbling
uh and uh you know
so i i was like maybe if i tell that
story
it will put into not just words but
really
peel back the curtain and explain how
and why we're
coming out this way and
sometimes as a consumer i'm also
fascinated with
why and i don't want to just be told
here it is
i want to know the process and the back
story so
i hope that i don't know about different
but i hope that what we do accomplish
is really bringing into light every
person who works on this show
and the fact that no person is one thing
and one mood and one tone and one taste
every day we are all full of diverse
eclectic interests and life is this
you know a complex fantastic interesting
uncomfortable wonderful journey we're
all on it we
like self-improvement we like music and
food and love and laughter and
leading with emotion pop culture junkies
and news and information
and putting the light on these stories
and people
that we shouldn't have to aggregate to
get to because
as responsible citizens we've got to
listen to the news and we and we do and
we should
but there are also other stories to be
told so i really want to
do that in drew's news and i just want
to have fun and interesting
conversations
and i love comedy it's my medicine in
life
and i want to bring sort of a late night
feel to daytime in that way of
i want to bring comedy to daytime
i love that i i heard that you were
going to do that and i was like yes
because
late night seems to get to have all that
fun and that's
you know i love so then has jimmy fallon
giving you any advice or any
like have you guys talked back and forth
yeah
you know his wife is my partner of 25
years i've been lucky
to be a fly on the wall you know for
all his uh you know over a decade
you know of him doing late night and
then the tonight show
yeah i i definitely pick his brain and i
trust him
and the one thing that i know
about jimmy is that
i am who you think i am and jimmy is
really that heart and enthusiasm he's
that nice to people
all the time there is no faking it when
it comes to him
that said he works extremely hard he
is very involved and innovating
i mean he when he came on late night
people were not doing viral
and games and bringing the sense of
variety to it
and then when he did the home show it
was so
personal and lovely and just had this
tone he really is incredible
at what he does so it's something that
he works hard
on but he doesn't have to work hard at
it is in him
that heart that's his heart i would say
the same about you
when we watch you in everything you do
you have such a big heart and you're so
you're really in it like you're not
doing it just because
whether it's your beauty stuff or
you know movies or television shows
documentaries you're in it and same with
this show
thank you thank you for saying that it
means
so much to me and i've been raised in an
industry where
you know name slapping is there's
nothing wrong with it
you know why not uh but i think i just
i'm too much of an
obsessor and too interested and too
involved i always
want to play with everyone who's sort of
problem solving
and setting the tone and figuring things
out and creating
that was always where i wanted to play
and be
so it's a good outlet i have so much
i think on my headstone it's going to
say death by inspo
i can't even take how much i love
and am interested in so many aspects of
life
that if i don't have an outlet to put it
in i'll just be in a straight jacket
so but that's what's going to make the
show so incredible
oh good i won't be in a straight jacket
and hopefully
we will get to i am also a learner i'm a
student
i don't know at all i've never been like
expert on anything i'm like
no i'm flawed i'm messy i want to figure
it out i do get there it might take too
long at times
sometimes it's fast it's all different
roads
and i love self-improvement i don't want
to stay stuck
i want to figure it out i love my kids
the most
i didn't know what the purpose of my
life was
i thought i had some ideas i didn't know
until i met them
but i'm really glad i'm at this place in
this moment
i have much to learn and i just want to
learn it with people
i like a sense of community i love
people i've been talking to people
every day in my life since i was seven
months seven years old
i went to work at 11 months old so this
feels
uh like i this feels
really like a privilege to get to do
where it needs to be
well speaking of people i mean can you
do a little name dropping who's going to
be on the
show what have you got you know in terms
of wanting to learn from other people
and other celebrity friends like
who have you got i definitely will be
learning from
you know experts themselves and chefs
and i love design and i love
news i love interesting stories and
aggregating sort of
everything that's happening um in the
culture
but i also want to learn from people i
haven't met yet
and okay and shine a light on them and
then
i am very lucky that some people i told
her our
talent booker ashley i said good luck
ashley on this job no one's ever coming
to this show
and she was like and i was like no i i
think that because i'm just a really
unassuming person
and then our first week lineup i'm
like are you kidding me we have and then
any person who's coming on the show
i have lived in hollywood my whole life
i am not at fabulous dinner parties i'm
not insider baseball chick
i work hard and i keep my head down and
i have the same friends i've had for 30
and 40 years
so i feel like i'm going to be able to
represent
all of us when someone's here that we're
all crazy about
because i feel that the same way too i
am not cool
and i want to be i am as excited as
anybody
who will be watching if that person
comes on the show
i love that well a charlie's angels
reunion is on the first
episode i mean that's epic can you
believe it's been 20 years
you know yeah in a weird way i can we've
had like
births deaths life love happiness
sadness uh you know breakups makeups
just everything a life
has in it we've actually gotten to
experience with each other
yeah and then occupationally we're all a
part of something that still to this day
is something we're so proud and honored
to be a part of
and just to support friendship and
i just thought if i could write a love
letter on day one to the people who have
had such an effect and an influence on
my life and the things i've gotten to do
that that felt so true to me
and so i'm just very lucky that they all
said yes to showing up because again i'm
not an assuming person and i'm so much
more about the give than the get so
i'm like thrilled that i get to do this
with them and really be myself and
for everyone else who gets to come on i
can't wait to do interviews too i love
journalistic you know integrity i love
the research
i love the art of the interview the
disarming conversation
i loved growing up on television that
took its time a little and you got to
have
longer content pieces yeah yeah where
you can get
you feel like i was saying actually to
my husband the other day my son and i
were talking about interviews and all
that kind of stuff
and i said my favorite part is when you
get in a conversation
and it's like the engine went off and
it's just floating and it's just
you find the space where you're just and
it's that art of conversation
but in longer format shows like yours
that's where we'll get that right
that is my goal for sure and then also
i'm like
do you have a character you miss and
want to bring
on to the show you own that character
let's do this let's do sketch comedy do
you want to
do this i'm sort of trying to offer like
a menu of options
or say is there something you would like
to do
it's not because we don't know what
we're doing or have a format but i kind
of want to spark imagination
and playfulness so i love good
conversation so if it's that
i'm in if there's something else to do
i probably would be into that too oh i
love it so much well
i'm getting the wrap thank you so much
i'm so excited that you're on our
network and we will be
promoting you and cheering you on and it
will be a huge success so
congratulations
i'm your sibling show yeah we're sisters
basically
i love it with like a love of good hair
let's do this i'm so happy to thank you
for having me on your show i'm cheering
you on
and let's do this again please we will
we'll come to an onset when we're
allowed one day
yeah yeah okay be well drew thanks again
you too thank you again
you